hey guys how's it going welcome back to
cooking with Justine I'm Justine and
today guess what we're going to be doing
we're going to be cooking now one of my
favorite foods is cheeseburgers so today
we're going to be making a new take on
dinner and since I kind of wanted this
to be a little bit festive for the
football season I tried to think what
was easy to make that would look like a
football and I'm gonna make some little
croissants to dip into our cheeseburger
cheese mix the captain for this Walmart
MVP contest is Jimmy Wong so he's making
his take on dip so I'm excited to see
what he creates and as a reminder all
you guys have to do if you want to win a
chance to come out here and hang out
with all of us we'll go to the YouTube
space we'll make some cooking videos you
just have to take a picture of your take
on dip post it on Instagram and use the
hashtag Walmart MVP contests enough
chatting let's get started okay first
things first
where's my meat okay I think I'll do
that in a second these totally look like
footballs I learned how to open one of
these for my sister Bree in the previous
video pressman against seme we're going
to roll you guys out make you into
little teeny tiny footballs roll it oh
this is nice I love food alright bake 9
to 12 minutes cool so it says I have to
cook this on medium heat
alright medium heat looks good
just cooking the beef cooking the beef
alright that looks like it's done
so I'll turn that off look at this our
ground beef is nicely cooked nicely
prepared slice an already cooked bacon
you could use freshly cooked bacon but I
just went for some bacon bits because it
was easy so you're going to put the
ground beef in to this pan here you can
use more or less the taste I'm clearly
using quite a lot so mix in your bacon
they're gonna want 4 ounces of cream
cheese more or less to taste so we're
going to use this much also recommends
1/2 cup of sour cream more or less to
taste we'll use about that much 1/2 cup
of mozzarella 1/2 cup of cheddar cheese
just a real nice mixture I think I may
want to mix this in a bigger bowl and
then put it back in here probably should
have done that from the beginning but
now this all makes sense so you guys
could not make the same mistake that I
made also needs a tablespoon of
Worchester sauce worship war chest Shire
sauce that is work shyster sauce that's
definitely a tablespoon a fourth cup of
mayonnaise more or less to taste that's
my disclaimer two tablespoons of ketchup
I love ketchup so I'm going to be
putting a little more ketchup than
recommended look Maddie this is
something that you can't have I'm in my
jammies don't worry my NATO son looks
good mmm
all right then mix all of your things
together here we go all this looks good
I wish you like meat Jenna because this
would be something you'd be into put it
back in here because this is we got to
bake this now to make it all come
together nicely come together right now
I'm going to put a few of the bacon bits
on the top and we're into a little swap
we're gonna check our football
croissants oh these totally look like
footballs at least one of them does and
put in our cheese mixture
bake that and then we'll do our final
presentation I've got my seemingly
beautiful croissant footballs made here
think yours will probably look better
now gonna get my cheese dip from the
oven this looks absolutely fabulous Oh
Oh
it's like sizzling all right we're gonna
get this nice little Bowl and we're
gonna put it in the center fabulous and
put our little footballs right around it
I might have to tell people that these
are footballs or we could just say hey
this is uh I don't know spoon some of
this into here
all right guys and there you have it my
take on dip actually looks not not too
shabby I'm I'm kind of impressed and I'm
gonna take the most football looking
croissant that I've I've created here
and let's uh let's give it a try it's so
good oh my gosh I am beyond shocked
right now because I didn't expect it to
be actually this delicious I just made
dinner is what I've just made thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
guys enjoyed this video
I am beyond impressed with what I just
made I kind of made the recipe up from
another recipe and sort of made it my
own which is what this whole challenge
is all about it's your take on bit as a
reminder this is a part of the Walmart
MVP contest so if you guys want to enter
to win a chance to come out to LA to
hang with me and the other Walmart MVP
captains it's super simple all you have
to do take a picture of your take on dip
posted on Instagram use the hashtag
that's all you guys have to do so I will
see you later I'm gonna go eat the rest
of this because this is my dinner it's
actually very good I'm so happy right
now
you